شكراً لك
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
شكرًا لك أن
الرئيس بايدن
تجنب تعثرًا كارثيًا
من
شأنه أن يؤدي إلى انهيار الاقتصاد وإلحاق الضرر
بملايين الأمريكيين كل يوم ،
توصل الرئيس بايدن إلى
قرار من شأنه تعليق
سقف الديون في  سنتان على الأقل
أجنبية
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
شكرًا لك
[موسيقى]
لأنها
بدأت هذه الليلة
ولكنك تعلم
[تصفيق]
الجوزاء هذا ليس عشبًا رائعًا بعيدًا عن
مستويات أعلى من المساحة المغطاة من أجل
استخراج  الاتفاق هنا
على هذا
لأن الجمهوريين أوصلونا إلى
النقطة
[تصفيق]
وستخرج هذه الصفقة ملايين
الأمريكيين من الفقر من خلال
تعزيز متطلبات العمل نظرًا لأن
كسب أغلبية الجمهوريين في مجلس النواب
قد استخفوا به من قبل وسائل الإعلام
كل يوم قللنا من تقديرنا
وسائل الإعلام هذا الأسبوع لكننا سنعمل
بلا كلل في الوفاء بوعودنا
وتحقيق النتائج للشعب الأمريكي